medical goal 102 from the free-throw
line and see what his numbers are in the
playoffs he had some very good stretches
during the regular season
a couple of months we were shooting
around 74-75 percent
these free throws presented by youtube
tv watch live tv no cable box required
scan the qr code now to try
for free for four free two weeks
he has definitely picked up the pace at
the line and so has the crowd in the
account
one two three four five
[Applause]
and that one a perfect point he's had an
air ball tonight
he's had two overshadowing you know the
free throw stuff
this this young man's one of the great
success stories in the history of the
nba
born in athens one of five boys as a kid
he was a street vendor
sold watches and dvds and cds for his
family to make money
to play basketball in greece he had to
share his pair of sneakers
with his brother thanasis they would
trade off him when each was played
now he's a two-time mvp he's got a 228
million dollar contract playing in the
nba finals
he gives a pair of those sneakers away
to a young boy or girl after every game
now
he's thoughtful he's he's hard-working
he's team first
it's a great american success story what
this man
has accomplished in his young life
and his brother's the ultimate height
being surrounded by lopez
[Applause]
hooker for three got it devin bucker
with a seven
footer right on him
be legendary and he's not disappointed
making big time shots for the phoenix
suns
leading them in the back the crowder
[ __ ] for three
deandre ate the rebound paul for three
you